-Well, guys, of course
everyone is still talking
about the coronavirus.
And I got to be honest,
things are getting
a little crazy out there.
Today in Central Park,
I saw a squirrel rubbing Purel
on his nuts.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-The coronavirus doesn't see
like it's slowing down,
and now the governor
of New Jersey has declared
a state of emergency.
It's serious.
The last time this happene
was when they ran out of pinky
rings at a "Soprano" convention.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, there hasn't been a
state of emergency in New Jersey
since the great track suit fir
of '98.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, because of the virus,
the mayor of Boston announce
that their annual St. Patrick'
Day Parade has been cancelled.
[ Audience groans ]
The mayor asked
if instead of drinking, puking
and blacking out in the streets,
people could make the mature
choice and do it at home.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey.
-This week,
New York governor Andrew Cuomo
introduced a new brand
of hand sanitizer
that's being made by the state
of New York called NYS Clean
Yep, and here he is talkin
about what it smells like.
-A little, I detect, lilac
[ Laughter ]
Hydrangea, tulips.
What does it smell like to you
Tulips, yes.
Floral bouquet.
[ Laughter ]
-What's that smell like to you
-He's like
a germaphobic sommelier.
He said it smells like a flora
bouquet. And the state also made
some other scents that reall
say "New York." For instance
there's Times Square Elmo
After A 12-Hour Shift.
[ Laughter ]
-Mm, sweat?
Mm, cigarettes? Mm.
-There's also Summertime Garbage
Behind Bubba Gump Shrimp.
[ Laughter ]
Then there's Uber Driver
Who Just Stopped For Shawarma.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-And of course,
Penn Station Bathroom
After A Crocs Convention.
-Oh. Mm.
[ Laughter ]
Get this, guys.
Harvard just announced
that they're sending
all of their students home
until further notice,
and they'll take classes online.
Now if you meet someone who says
they went to Harvard,
you can be like, "Oh, that
online school?"
[ Laughter ]
Finally. Finally.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on. Give him something
What's that smell like to you?
-Meanwhile, today,
"Wheel of Fortune"
filmed without an audience
as a protective measure
against the coronavirus.
Things are so bad over there
Vanna is now turning
all the letters with her elbow
[ Dinging ]
[ Laughter ]
[ As Pat Sajak ]
There are five S's.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Meanwhile, President Trump's
brand-new Chief of Staff,
Mark Meadows,
has already
"self-quarantined" himself
Not because of the virus.
On his first day,
he looked around,
and he was like, "Aw, hell no.
I'm not ready for this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Some more political news -
Today was Super Tuesday 2.0,
with primaries
in six different states.
Yeah, for six states, it was
all about Biden versus Bernie.
For everyone else, it was
Hannah Ann versus Madison.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right? Tonight --
Tonight was the big season
finale of "The Bachelor."
Oh, my goodness.
[ Cheers and applause ]
For months, we've seen Peter
travel the world,
kiss lots of women,
introduce them to his parents --
basically all the things you
shouldn't do during a pandemic
That's right, tonight was part 2
of "The Bachelor" season finale.
And Pete had to choose between
two very qualified women,
or as Democrats put it, lucky.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And last night,
we finally got to see
one of the most anticipate
moments of the season.
And many people
were shocked to find out
Peter's mom was talking
about Hannah Ann,
not Madison, in this moment.
-Hannah Ann loves you
with all of her heart.
Don't let her go.
Bring her home.
Bring her home to us.
[ Laughter ]
-She was like,
"I just want you to be happy
for the next
three to six months."
[ Laughter ]
Come on. A little overreacting
Tone it down, Mom.
Take two.
Mom, do it again.
Tone it down a little bit.
-What does this smell like
-[ Imitates sobbing,
stammering ]
Okay, stop. One more take.
Just take it down
a little notch.
And finally,
this is going viral.
In Ohio, a little boy
had his first wrestling match,
and things didn't go as planned.
Take a look.
-Alright, ready?
[ Whistle blows ]
-Wrestle, Jay.
[ Laughter ]
-He was like,
"Did you see the other guy
He must have been
like 2 feet tall!"
We have a great show!